if you have a condition in your neck
that puts pressure on your spinal cord
or spinal nerves your doctor may
recommend an anterior cervical disc
ectomy and fusion the spine in your neck
also called the cervical spine has seven
separate Bones called vertebrae
the front of each vertebra is called the
vertebral body except for the first
vertebra
between most vertebrae is a soft cushion
called an intervertebral disc
the back part of each vertebra has a
curved section called the vertebral arch
except for the first vertebra each
vertebral arch has a bony projection
called the spinous process on each side
of the spinous process is a flat piece
of bone called a lamina
the vertebral arch of the vertebra
surrounds and protects your spinal cord
a column of nervous tissue connecting
your brain to other nerves in your body
your spinal cord passes through an
enclosed space called the vertebral
canal which is formed by the vertebral
arches of your vertebrae
over time your cervical spine may
develop problems such as a bulging disc
a herniated or ruptured disc
or bony growths on your vertebrae called
bone spurs
these changes can narrow your vertebral
canal and put pressure on your spinal
cord or the nerves that branch off of it
the pressure can cause neck pain and
stiffness or pain numbness and weakness
in your arms or hands
your surgeon will make an incision on
your neck
the front of your cervical spine
containing the damaged disc will be
exposed
your surgeon will remove the entire
damaged disk this helps relieve the
pressure on your spinal cord and nerve
roots
then your surgeon will remove any bone
spurs
the vertebral bodies above and below the
removed discs will be trimmed to allow
placement of a bone graft
your surgeon may use a plastic spacer
filled with synthetic bone graft
or bone graft maybe taken from another
donor before your procedure
the bone graft will be placed between
the two prepared vertebrae allowing them
to fuse together
your surgeon may attach a metal plate
with screws to keep your spine stable
while your bone graft assists in fusing
the vertebrae together
your skin incision will be closed with
skin glue or skin closure tape
your neck may be placed in a collar to
keep it still while your vertebrae fuse